pues al menos seis personas atacadas con
un arma blanca artesanal en la estación
de París Norte Como mencionabas en la
madrugada de este miércoles las víctimas
son cinco pasajeros y un agente de la
policía de fronteras el autor del hecho
fue abatido rápidamente por dos policías
que le dispararon e hirieron permanece
hospitalizado en estado grave por el
momento se desconocen la identidad del
individuo porque no portaba documentos y
los motivos de su agresión la fiscalía
antiterrorista declaró que permanece
atenta pero no ha tomado las riendas de
la investigación el hecho de se
clasifica como una tentativa de
asesinatos algo que pudiera cambiar en
las próximas horas sin embargo este tipo
de incidente lamentablemente no es
inédito en febrero del año pasado un
atacante con arma blanca fue Igualmente
abatido por la policía en esa estación
ferroviaria y en esa zona del distrito
diez de París ocurren con frecuencia
episodios violentos de hecho los
comerciantes se quejan de que la
delincuencia afecta sus negocios ya en
este momento los trenes cir normalmente
por la terminal que es una de las más
grandes de la capital convergen allí
varias líneas del metro local trenes
regionales y grandes líneas que cubren
trayectos internacionales